hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 73 of game
programming so today we're gonna talk
about rate of fire because last time we
talked about arranged and basically I
set up that I'd talk about out of fire
so I'm going to talk about right of fire
well show you guys how to implement
right fire into our projectile system so
first of all I'm well what is rate of
fire well essentially right a fire is um
a way to slow down the speed at which we
fire how projectiles right or rather
define the speed at which we fire our
projectiles so you can see that they're
actually firing so fast actually on top
of each other and that's kind of cool
but yeah maybe not right we want to sort
of space out the projectiles and
essentially not fire them so fast right
so that we only fire one let's say we
can only fire like because right now
we'll be firing 60 per second so let's
just say we want to fire maybe like 10 a
second or something like that okay we
just want to slow it down now you can
actually seen it was a projectile we've
already got a variable called rate of
fire which I implemented here and the
way the road if I is gonna want to work
and this might be a bit well what's the
word I'm looking for
basically the hi the ratify the slow up
we're gonna fire them okay that's just
how it's gonna work because rather than
write a fire we could think of this
number as being the the time in between
projectiles right so the way that is
essentially gonna happen is let's say
well the way that needs to happen is in
the playout variable right so which is
why it's kind of questionable to keep it
there I guess because essentially we
just want to not shoot very often so
what does shoot do let's check out let's
check out our um shoot method so what
true does is it just it essentially just
creates a new project a essentially
tonight anyway it creates a new
projectile and an answer to the level
yeah now what we want to say is let's
not create a new projectile that often
yeah let's just wait a bit so the simple
way to do this
and this isn't mob of course but the
simple way to do this is to grab a
static ratify so I might actually remove
right of fire from here and instead I
might just have a public static final
int cold Freight or rather fire right
and we'll make that 15 which is what it
was
let's just do this to make it look nice
and I might actually just remember from
here well we don't have to yeah we will
write Phi let's get rid of that cable
speed and range everything but because
the reason that I'm doing this again is
because write a fire is um defining how
often the objects are being created yeah
all these things were actually internal
write a fires external so we can have to
move it to a place that is external so
what we need to do here is um say that
what should happen is in player dot
whoops in our player class we've got an
update method so we need to say that if
wizard projectile dot fire rate is
greater than zero then we should as
final as them we shouldn't have made it
final to go back to you or we could make
it final and we could yeah this will
probably be much better so let's just
say the player has a gun and it's his
gun has a fire is so let's make a fire
rate for our player yeah fire rate
equals zero for now and then in this
instance since we've got wizard
projectile then in fact it's probably
better to do it this way
projectile pay yeah that's kind of like
the gun that our player has so
essentially I probably should have made
weapons rather than projectiles but it's
a matter of the container
what they've been waiting labeling that
we'll see so let's just set P equal to
well it was it projectile essentially
but we probably don't want to make it a
thing yeah you know what
well Craig guns later and what we'll do
that system then but for now and weapons
I guess not necessarily guns Woolsey but
let's set the fire right now I pulled a
wizard projectile dot fire right yeah
and what we should do here is say that
as long as our fire rate is greater than
zero
let's try and you know let's just
subtract stuff from that and and if we
do actually shoot so an update shooting
if we do actually clip we want to make
sure that we after we shoot obviously
that we set our fire rate back to the
wizard reject holder fire and that we
only shoot if we click and our fire rate
is actually less of equal to zero
I just think it's probably better to say
less than or equal to zero yeah so if we
check this out what you'll see is we've
got a much slower fire rate here now
what we can do here is we go into mob
where are we printing this stuff from
the size of our projectile right with
that being a level or in play uh I just
want to get rid of that
I think some level because that's why
the thing is right know at some level oh
here we go
hear that so that we don't print
anything out console all right so wait
so if we go into wizard projectile here
and we change the fire rate to like five
you'll actually see that we actually
fire faster see and if I change it to
something like 50 well I'm gonna fire
pretty slow you can see just how slow
that is yes that might be something like
a sniper which would which has really
really really long range which would be
kind of useless for this all this would
be cool here's an idea maybe but maybe
in the future we could make a sniper
weapon that's like a like a sniper rifle
and if you hit right click it just zooms
out you display a lot so you can kind of
aim long ranger than you could fire that
would be pretty cool but yeah well for
this weather wizard projectile I think
if Shane was pretty good
like maybe a bit too slow maybe 10 so
just so you guys know her high and
higher is slower just keep that in mind
okay that's pretty good
I'm gonna leave it to that okay so wait
so that's how you that's how you do fire
right hope you guys enjoy this episode
of game programming if you did please
hit a like button and I'll see you guys
hopefully very soon exam time is coming
up at Union I've got a few portfolios
finished one portfolio finish and one
exam to do so um I am kind of busy but I
hope that I'll be I'll have time to make
you guys videos because I enjoy doing it
so yeah anyway hit the like button I'll
see you guys next time - bye
you